[Music]
no news submitted by Wow mom Wow like a
confession we all do nice suit often I'm
very vocal about that
okay elite elite was pulled from a
woman's throat after going in from tumor
surgery
uh from the inside of her [ __ ]
throat not like on her neck no because
then you would have set off her neck oh
wait so they were like getting the tumor
out and they're like oh also there's a
leech there was a leech in there where
did they put the leech in there on
purpose to do some evidence you know
sometimes they put maggots on certain
wounds to eat the infected area imagine
that you split your brain open they put
some bug in there or like a little leech
in there and then they put it back
together they're massive they're like a
movie I feel like I've seen that in a
movie and then the bug you could see it
crawling into the skin
yeah you'd only see that in the movie
that's it yeah
with a little by the thing you could
yeah I'm just uh making the thing
there's another there's another there's
another really big ol beetle
[Music]
all right so this happened to a 63 year
old woman Vietnam expected yeah right
they're [ __ ] dogs in Vietnam yeah
they're badass that's what she didn't
give a [ __ ] she's like I just have a
horse throwback
she's like book it just part of trying
to eat the leech oh well the tumor oh
the leech like gets rid of the tumor
yeah it was it torn her throat so when
she went to the hospital complaining of
what does she learn okay short throat
for our make sort elbow I know something
totally not even corns on her feet
[Laughter]
painful headaches I'm like I know a lot
about her throat
I just forgot the exact thing but yeah
she was complaining about painful
headaches so she went to the hospital
and they diagnosed her with having a
throat tumor that needed to be removed
so when they went in during surgery
that's when they found a living leech
and the patient's sinuses Wow and they
also report throat so I'm just as
confused as you probably four [ __ ]
six months oh dude I don't know this do
leeches get me agree they pull it out
from like from like you know your throat
there's a video there making videos Oh
he came out of his throat but I'm saying
like it was probably up there and I
grabbed it yeah it's all connected we
just get bigger the more they yeah I
think they suck blood and they get
bigger like filled with so they take a
[ __ ] didn't go they get smaller again
this leech was two inches all my lord
know how long the leech is living a nerd
throat yeah six years no that's two
months three months three months
okay tip not tell me my prize there you
go water here you know more water do
I'll have a chugging contest with you I
think I could beat you in water or
[Applause]
healthy finally you're gonna feel so
good I do feel very nice that's the
second time someone's chugged a bottle
of water on JK news you know the first
time was Julia do you remember that
really you are the biggest [ __ ] fan
ever
I love it you're the trivia Julia she
was like her mom didn't want her to
drink cold water or something like that
and then she was like
oh yeah you guys probably weren't here
and then she's like guess what mom I
think I was here for that all right so
I'm going to show you guys the video of
this entire than happening no no I
forward it cuz it takes a while I'm not
watching I want to see you
nope it's like I can't look away oh we
did like that
I'll watch your face oh that's a leech
called arange or whether they shouldn't
have a way more nefarious name for it
than that
so they're saying that she was swimming
in the natural spring and drank the
water and somehow like ever went in I'm
disgusted she was bathing in spring
water yeah so it's like when Joe is in
Hawaii thought he got the route worn one
long or whatever that she actually
caught something yeah I feel like I'm
always like let's swim in this random
spring yeah I don't like it you know
ever since I saw this questionnaire
after that what I was doing but it said
something about like have you recently
swam in any river no Mike [ __ ] that I'm
never swimming in river water is like
the worst yeah you can get some all
kinds of [ __ ] yes if it's still but if
it's like running that's like it's
better
no running waters I always get so scared
um just because I feel like something's
gonna enter my [ __ ] vagina hole oh
that's like in the Amazon River a
[ __ ] hole yeah like you guys have a
little people and your [ __ ] legs are
open you swim with a vagina and butt
plugs in you're fine
in the Amazon River though that if you
pee in it the extra swims up the pee
stream into your urethra and it spikes
out that's real I feel like that's only
for guys because a penis straight line
or girls we kind of like you good what
guys bathroom and see if you pee in a
straight line that the logic goes our
bathroom see if the guys pay the same
[Laughter]
alcohol vodka I knew it
gin actually yeah it's pretty gross but
I learned something new about leeches a
that I don't know like is just say to me
what was it let's have contrary to
popular belief most leeches don't rely
on drinking blood to survive some of you
other small animals and some feed off
decomposing bodies what was she feeding
what was this one feeding on so they're
saying that blood sucking leeches only
suck about a teaspoon of blood and when
they're full they naturally fall off so
this one never let go though so as maybe
it was eating decomposing [ __ ] in her
throat oh she can't feel [ __ ] moving in
hearth right it was wiggling when they
bow maybe it was too constricted if it's
in your esophagus can you really feel
like maybe he was just connected to her
throat like this and he was being still
and then when they like trying to get
him as a baby he only moves when she
moves so she's not what is that she
stops and that I stop see that guy
starts like moving - it's like bugs
money they're like well she's talking
he's just like dancing and she's quiet
and then she has she's listening for it
and then he's like holding his breath
yeah they're saying that leeches feed on
blood by making us small by making small
cuts in their prey skin and then
covering it in their saliva which numbs
the area and increases blood flow that
way well that's [ __ ] s'more so you
don't feel when there's leeches on
that's why you don't do that - because I
like never will you catch those all the
time
I can never feel when they're doing that
because we're having a conversation she
goes yeah she'd be like both imagine
what's gonna sting I can feel it like no
the only time of my life I give catch it
because I remember we're talking and I
was like took me a minute to be like I
actually wouldn't even mind if they bit
me and there was no bite like there's no
like oh they weren't that wasn't all
itchy em hit me and left me a lot be
completely if I go ahead feed off me all
you see spread diseases though that's
why I'm like [ __ ] you yeah wait tipsy
you you don't do this all the time you
don't just get them as they're coming in
you don't like John wicking these
mothers seems like a John wick in Mexico
John wick three
yeah we're just talking about it earlier
look sick I was like let me guess what
happens they destroyed his kitchen a he
was in the middle of a remodel this is
40 grand spanish-style you guys are
probably crazy like I'm gonna kill all
of you yeah did you see the second one
yeah I am a [ __ ] fan of those movies
man third God so is he they are great
movies it's the stupidest plot but you
just glued it the second one was tied
[ __ ] I thought what they wanted him to
come back to the industry and he's like
no and then they burned his house down
to show you [ __ ] wasn't bad
second one was wouldn't he was in the
Continental Hotel thing and it was a
damn piece there yeah and they can't
fight in there and then he's
excommunicated on now because he he
fought in there and killed the guy no
but but he didn't want to come back to
the industry he all was only there
because they were making him come back
he needed to do that one favor get a
flower right here don't say no to me and
then say the rest of the story
oh I was not wrong I wasn't saying
you're wrong I was just an elaborate
but this drill for the third one looks
so [ __ ] sick
it's crazy human to register funny no
but I just saw the first one with
everyone who were in Hawaii and I walked
out of there like how did this get made
this is [ __ ] bad oh you're actually
there it's so fun it's a 90 on Rotten
Tomatoes I'll give them the action right
oh really dog but everything else I'm
like this is such a stupid ass movie I
thought it was a comedy I was laughing
it's funny what's your favorite movie
Jeff I'm gonna take a big [ __ ] [ __ ]
on it right now so I can take the
biggest Angus [ __ ] donkey and spread
are we not dating
no I'm talking about how she offended my
sensibilities go ahead to my opinions do
oh no this one's not an opinion do you
like um did you see the equalizer no
it's kind of like the Denzel Washington
version of John we clip true he
equalizes it what the body counts like
nine I like men on fire at first if he
destroys it the whole [ __ ] City
no I know but but I'm talking about body
count versus John wicked Aubry I wonder
if there's some nerd out there that's
cold oh that's gonna be I would I always
wonder like you know when there's this
big ol explosion how are you gonna count
that huh
are you also viewing it through like an
action-movie lens doing it through
action movies because one of the
craziest things about it is that all the
martial arts with guns like when he's
punching and blasting that's just like I
remember how I felt about it that's it I
don't remember the actual again the
action scenes are and I think you'll be
alright if you don't watch it
no you won't if we're gonna watch it one
more time and you're gonna like it like
and then you're gonna say I liked it
visually watch it with you if you drink
five gallons of water yeah a day for how
long for until you guys make you
pregnant
well that's a big ass it's like a
monumental you know I'm no deal
I don't want to get too I don't wanna
get pregnant by some dehydrated man oh
I'll be hydrated for that well let's see
oh yeah
[Music]
you